This beautiful knit weave stitch pattern
combines automatic patterning to form
the knit weave floats
along with picking up the long
floats manually for graphic appeal.
The DesignaKnit stitch
pattern looks like this.
The weave over symbol selects needles
and the weaving yarn
passes over those needles.
However, DesignaKnit  does not have
a symbol for picking up those long floats.
We will Follow this diagram
for picking up the floats.
Looking at the punch card,
the black squares or the holes
indicate the weaving floats.
The white squares are stitches that knit.
Let's walk through the 16 row
repeat for this stitch pattern.
I'm using a Brother machine,
so the needles are pre-selecting.
But with Singer, Silver, Studio,
and other machines,
follow your manual for knit weave and pick
up the floats as shown in the diagram.
The first pass of my carriage
sets up the first row.
I like to manually lay the weaving yarn
over the selected needles, but you can
use the knit weave method of your choice.
When I knit across my first row,
notice there are seven stitches between
the selected needles and There's
a long float between those needles.
The second row of the pattern is the same,
creating another seven-stitch float.
Now on my Brother machine,
I can see that there are no
needles selected for the next row.
It will knit plain.
Keeping the weaving yarn out of the way,
according to the pattern,
I'll just knit two rows.
The pattern has preselected
groups of three needles.
Before I weave the next row, however,
I'll pick up both of those large floats
from below and hang them
on the center of a group of three.
I'll do this across the row.
Then, according to the pattern,
I'll weave the next four rows.
Notice the shorter floats.
The next sequence of two
rows creates long floats.
Notice that the long floats are
alternating in position
from the first group of long floats.
When these two rows are complete,
I'll knit two plain rows.
Groups of three needles are selected.
Before knitting the next section,
pick up the long floats and hang them
on the center needle of the groups
of three, just like before.
Knit four rows of short floats again.
And repeat the sequence starting
with two rows of long floats.
Here's my booboo.
As I was working this stitch pattern,
I caught myself passing my carriage too
far from the edge of the knitting,
forming loops on edges. This is something
to watch for any time you're knitting.
In this case, I was more worried about
positioning that weaving yarn and lost
focus about how far I
was passing my carriage.